it's fair to say you've spent a few
thousand hours with El Ron Hubbard yes
okay perfect so let's set that aside
that's that's you know you're a disciple
you've witnessed so it's not like a
person that's speaking theoretically you
are in the disciple category and how
many people in the world have spent a
few thousand hours around L Ron Hubbard
that are living today
uh probably less than a hundred okay so
less than a hundred so that's one in a
hundred who can speak with that kind of
experience now take L Ron Hubbards
because I've seen you say that uh L Ron
Hubbard had a temper as well but he was
more charismatic charming and a little
bit more you know easier to deal with
versus miscavige doesn't have that you
know his temper is worse so and you've
spent how many hours with Miss cabbage a
million okay so so but so the comparison
between the two a lot more with David
than you have with L Ron Hubbard right
yes correct what is the different style
of leadership with miscavige versus L
Ron Hubbard
miscavige doesn't really have any
redeeming qualities in that he has uh a
very very aggressive style and uh
uh a tendency to Violent outbursts that
are physical in nature
I I must people say oh yes miscarriages
are fool he is no fool he is a very
highly intelligent smart guy who says
he's a fool oh a lot of people uh on
social media or that they respond to me
or you know who or or people who
interview me they're like well you know
he's just crazy well crazy like a fox or
whatever he is a super super intelligent
guy who is capable of absorbing enormous
amounts of information and analyzing it
and figuring out how to use it for his
advantage
perhaps more so even than Hubbard
David miscavich is the perfect product
of elrond Hubbard
and by that I mean he too was raised a
Scientologist from a very young age and
had a similar sort of trajectory in life
that I did he joined the sea
organization as soon as he could out of
high school he sort of Rose through the
ranks he went and worked with Hubbard he
was a protege of Hubbard even more than
me he was with him when he was living in
California working every day for a year
with him in California
um
he also has a personality David
miscavich that lends itself to these
the being like the perfect disciple of
Hubbard in that Hubbard had a very mean
streak to him he
he there was a lot of writings in
Scientology about people who disagree
with Hubbard and what is to be done with
them and you know he says I I never
forget I'll always even the score I
never forgive people who have attacked
Scientology on me I will destroy them
utterly if possible of course these are
his words these are his words and
you
um
if you look at David miscavich that is
he the essence of David miscavage he has
got that part of Scientology down to a T
and
while he can be
um Charming when he wants to be like any
sociopath can I I mentioned in my book
that I read this brilliant book by a
woman a professor called Martha Stout
called the sociopath next door which I
recommend to anybody yeah and it had a
real impact on me because I realized the
book I realized look that I thought I
was dealing with a unique
person in David miscavige and obviously
he is unique there's no other David
miscavige's but there are a lot of other
sociopaths and they share a lot of
character characteristics and
I see miscavige as being a classic
sociopath and taking the bits that
Hubbard gave and using those to become
the the new lrun Hubbard of Scientology
for a long time uh science you you could
have said to any Scientologist will
there ever be another elrond Hubbard and
every one of them would say no and
probably all of them would agree with
that statement now but if you said to
them is David miscavich the the epitome
of elrond habad carrying forth his
legacy that every Scientologist would
agree with you about that and every
Scientologist today is as afraid of
criticizing questioning or challenging
The Authority or words of David
miscavich as they were elrond Hubbard so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
foreign
[Music]